Usa la gráfica de abajo para decidir cuales
de las siguientes ecuaciones son ciertas.
Nos muestran esta línea azul y vemos que
hay dos triángulos rectángulos
que están en esta línea y la tienen como hipotenusa.
Y aquí están todas las ecuaciones
que quieren que verifiquemos,
si es que son ciertas con respecto a esta gráfica.
Nosotros sabemos que la pendiente
de esta línea azul,
va a ser el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x"
y si vemos estos triángulos y analizamos
con respecto a estos dos puntos,
éste de acá y éste de acá, podemos ver
esta parte, este lado c
como el cambio en "y" y d como el cambio en "x".
Lo mismo si analizamos estos dos puntos de acá,
éste y éste otro,
este segmento a es nuestro cambio en "y"
y nuestro segmento b es el cambio en "x".
Y como hemos visto anteriormente, estos triángulos son semejantes porque,
la pendiente de la línea es constante.
Podemos decir que nuestros segmentos c...
c... entre el segmento d... va a ser igual,
esta proporción va a ser la misma que la
del segmento a entre el segmento b,
ésta y ésta, esta proporción va a ser la misma.
Muy bien, también nos están indicando
este punto de aquí, "x", "y".
Vamos a analizar cada una de estas ecuaciones para ver si son verdaderas o no.
La primera nos dice "y" más 4 entre "x"
más 4 es igual a "a" entre "b", vamos a ver.
Aquí está mi punto "x", "y", "y" más 4,
quiere decir que este punto de acá, bueno
este segmento que es "y",
todo este valor y a éste le agrego 4,
1, 2, 3, 4, llego hasta acá.
Entonces "y" más 4 es esta línea naranja.
Ahora, de este mismo punto me dicen que a "x", que es este valor, le agregue 4 también.
Se los puedo agregar hacia la
derecha o hacia la izquierda
y para claridad me conviene agregarlos
hacia la izquierda, éste es mi valor en "x",
que lo puedo tener también acá y a este
valor "x" que es,
éste de aquí le agrego 4,
1, 2, 3, 4,
muy bien, entonces tengo este
segmento de acá, en morado
y este segmento naranja y como esta parte es perfectamente horizontal
y esta parte es perfectamente vertical
forman un ángulo recto,
es un triángulo rectángulo y como están estos puntos sobre esta misma línea, representa la misma pendiente
y va a ser semejante, en proporción, va a
ser igual en proporción a estos otro triángulos
que están sobre esta misma línea.
Así que vamos a poner ésta naranjita como
"y" más 4 y ésta de aquí abajo, la moradita
es "x" más 4... "x" más 4.
Podemos decir que esta proporción, "a" entre
"b" es igual a la proporción de "y" más 4...
"y" más 4 que es el lado que corresponde
al lado "a" entre "x" más 4 que es el lado
que le corresponde al lado "b",
éste de acá abajo, "x"más 4.
Estos son iguales en proporción,
por lo que ésta es verdadera.
La siguiente es "x" más 4 entre "y" más
4 igual a "a" entre "d".
Bueno, de hecho ésta está mezclada porque
pues "a" es el lado de un triángulo y "d"
es el lado de otro triángulo y como que no
tiene nada que ver entre ellos, así que no,
de entrada ésta, está mal porque tiene los
términos revueltos.
La siguiente, "b" entre "a" igual a "c" entre
"d", bueno, de hecho no,
no es así porque vemos aquí que "c" es proporcional a "a" y "d" es proporcional a "b",
son los lados correspondientes, y aquí pues está invertido y aquí no es así,
entonces bueno,  esta opción no es.
La última opción, "c" entre "d" igual a "a" entre "b" pues sí, es exactamente lo que tenemos aquí arriba,
la misma proporción, así que
esta última opción si es verdadera.
Y con esto, terminamos de resolver
el problema que nos piden.